SPEAKER: Our favorite
cat walking company
has been using Cloud
DLP to automatically
redact and replace sensitive
values from their data.
But what about data that
they need to protect
but still use for
things like billing?
Stick around and find out how
Cloud DLP's got them covered.
Kitty Cat Walks has already
implemented Cloud DLP
to apply redaction and
replacement in their issue
ticketing system so
they don't inadvertently
log any sensitive information
from their customers.
Their billing department,
on the other hand,
handles tons of
credit card numbers.
They need to protect
that information
but also access those
values to process
payments for their premium
cat walking service.
So while Cloud DLP
offers a bunch of options
to help you hide and remove
sensitive values in your data,
there's one technique
that leverages encryption
to de-identify
and, in some cases,
re-identify those
sensitive values.
Crypto-based tokenization,
also referred
to as pseudonymization, is
a powerful de-identification
technique that uses encryption
keys to replace sensitive data
values with cryptographically
generated tokens.
This method of
de-identification is especially
popular in industries like
finance and health care,
where protecting data is a
matter of utmost importance,
but preserving data
utility is still desired.
Cloud DLP supports three types
of cryptographic methods.
First is deterministic
encryption.
Here, the detected
data is replaced
with an encrypted
value and prepended
with an optional
surrogate annotation.
This method supports
most input types
and is authenticated,
which makes it
the most recommended
tokenization solution.
The next method is Format
Preserving Encryption, FPE.
Like deterministic
encryption, FPE
will replace the value
of an encrypted string,
except it's going to
be the same length
and use the same character
set as the original value.
This is the way
to go if you need
to retain support for
any legacy data systems
that have strict length
character set requirements.
The third method is
cryptographic caching.
Here, DLP replaces sensitive
data with a hash value.
Unlike the other two methods,
cryptographic caching
uses a one-way token so
it can't be reversed.
It's the perfect solution if
you want each unique value
to be transformed into a
corresponding unique hash
value, but don't necessarily
want it to be reversible.
More on that later.
One huge factor
that sets all three
of these apart from most other
de-identification techniques
is that they allow
us to securely
de-identify data while retaining
its referential integrity.
Referential integrity
allows records
to maintain the
relationship to one another,
even after being
individually identified.
For example, if
we have this table
of data with cryptographic
hashing applied
to one of its fields using
the same cryptographic key,
each of the unique values will
have a consistent transformed
value.
This means that data can be
de-identified for security
or compliance reasons, but still
used for business operations
and analytical workflows,
such as joining across tables
or aggregating data.
So another powerful
feature of tokenization
is the ability to
reverse the encryption
to re-identify the data.
Since deterministic encryption
and format preserving
encryption uses
symmetric encryption key
to tokenize data,
the same key can
be used to essentially
undo the de-identification
to reveal the original value.
The option to re-identify
expanse utility of Cloud DLP
so that data can be
securely obscured
and readable only by
systems authorized
to access the encryption
key and the output value.
Let's see how the DLP
API handles tokenization
by looking at this request
from a Node.js app.
In this example, we're going
to apply format preserving
encryption to the credit card
number field of this sample CSV
data that out set
to a variable myCSV.
This is the request
object that will
send to the de-identified
content function.
First, we want to specify the
CSV data that we want to scan.
In the de-identification
configuration,
we'll indicate a few things.
Here, in the
transformations array,
is where we indicate each
of the transformations we'd
like to apply.
In this case, we just want to
target the info type credit
card number and provide an
FPE configuration for format
preserving encryption.
There, we provide a
wrapped key, which
I've contained in the
variable myWrappedKey,
and the Cloud KMS key we used
to wrap it in the form of a KMS
resource name.
And I threw it into
the variable myKeyName.
We'll also specify that we want
to transform our data using
a numeric alphabet and
provide a surrogate info type
string that will be
prepended to each value.
The responses
function will include
the data we provided
in the request,
except with the credit
card numbers replaced
with an encrypted string and
prepended with a surrogate info
type we specified.
As you can see, each unique
value in our original data
remains unique after
transformation.
With its referential integrity
intact, in a larger data set
we'd still be able to analyze
the data without accessing
the sensitive values.
So how about re-indentification?
The re-indentified
content function
takes this request object.
It looks similar to the
de-identified content request,
except we'll be passing
our de-identified data.
As long as the surrogate info
type and the encryption key
we provide matches what we
use to tokenize our data,
the result will be
our original data
with the sensitive
values revealed.
Now that Kitty Cat Walks have
added crypto-based tokenization
to their DLP know-how, their
security and compliance teams
can sleep soundly knowing
that their customer billing
information is well-protected
on their systems.
Next time, we'll take what
they've learned so far
and see how they'll use it
to construct DLP templates so
that they can reuse inspection
and de-identification
rules across different
systems and processes.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]